hey guys dr. Mike Marshall Skye here
welcome to another episode of the
Wednesday checkup in the past that made
a Kovan 19 fact-checking video on
politicians media even conspiracy
theorists but today I want to focus on
President Trump and the reason I'm doing
this is not because of a political
motivation but simply because he's the
leader of the United States he's in
charge of making a lot of the decisions
that affect you and I in our day to day
lives
funding testing decisions about
potential treatments and vaccinations
and I think it's important to be
critical of our leaders so that we can
hold them accountable to the statements
and decisions they make I've been
following the media reports very closely
surrounding Coppa 19 there's been heavy
reporting both in the United States and
outside talking about how America has
failed in the Cova 19 pandemic and while
there's certainly truth to that need to
be fair no one can be truly prepared for
a pandemic we need to put that out there
also hindsight is 20/20 and everyone
loves to play Monday Morning Quarterback
that being said President Trump has made
several inaccurate statements that I'm
gonna cover here today as a leader you
want to project confidence you want to
project being alert not anxious however
that doesn't mean we should downplay
truly serious issues and throughout this
pandemic the messaging from President
Trump has been this I think that's a
problem that's gonna go what it's going
to disappear will go away it will go
away go away you know it is going away
this is going away this is gonna go away
guys leave coal pit 19 is gonna go away
it won't be a problem for the rest of
our lives
but to continually say this in the midst
of a pandemic when hundreds of thousands
of lives are being lost millions of
people are getting infected it's it's
just it's not an accurate representation
of what's going on your talking points
have to change when you get new numbers
it when I tell you at home to not look
at numbers every day that's because I
don't want you becoming anxious over
each of these numbers going up but as
the president of the United States a
person who's in charge of making really
important day-to-day decisions you have
to be looking at these numbers and
seeing that this problem isn't going
away in fact I think where president
Trump showed the least amount of
accuracy
in his speaking was on the day that I
published my video two weeks ago Kovach
cases are spiking
people are dying and the second wave
isn't even here yet and here's what
President Trump said that same day it's
dying out it's fading away it's going to
fade away fast forward now to two weeks
later the problem hasn't gone away it's
actually gotten so bad that the peak of
kovat 19 is higher than it was in April
we have to take this virus seriously
because if we don't you know what
happens it starts spiking again exactly
as it is happening right now
I've consistently preached that we need
personal responsibility a serious level
of personal responsibility in order to
stop or at least slow down this virus
meaning that we need to socially
distance ourselves we need to wear masks
wash our hands that being said there is
still something that our government
needs to do and that's testing that's
their responsibility we need to have
testing supplies available and we need
to make it at a price that's affordable
to everybody in fact it probably should
be covered by our government like it is
in many other countries president Trump
is going on stage and saying things like
this we've tested now 25 million people
here's the bad part when you test them
what you do testing to that extent
you're gonna find more people you're
gonna find more cases so I said that my
people slowed the testing down please I
can't imagine anyone at the CDC or any
respectable medical agency hearing a
president saying we should slow down
testing and taking him seriously here's
what his staff has said it was a comment
that he made and Jess it's a comment
that he made in passing you know it was
tongue-in-cheek that the president come
on now that was tongue-in-cheek but I
understand that there's not much of a
sense of humor at CNN center but the
president was joking so let's say he's
joking
why you're the leader of our nation
we're looking to you for information a
lot of people trust you and then after
his staff says it was a joke
president Trump says this
I don't kid let me make it clear so he's
not kidding on top of it when President
Trump says the numbers are going up
because we're testing more that is a
fallacy we are catching more cases but
at the same time we're having more and
more sick people and virus transmission
that is showed by increased
hospitalization rate and an increased
positivity rate on the people who we are
testing and in fact president Trump
leads us to believe that we have the
biggest testing capacity in the world
we're eight in per-capita testing in the
world not number one not number two
eight so we could do a better job and we
certainly shouldn't start slowing things
down now when the virus is at its
highest peak it's been let's chat
mortality rates just last week President
Trump tweeted coronavirus deaths are way
down mortality rate is one of the lowest
in the world we are the lowest in the
world we're somewhere in the mid 30s so
we're not the best in the world by any
means I'm not even a huge fan of
comparing all of these numbers there's
many countries in the world that don't
do a great job in keeping exact deaths
rates certificates of death there's all
sorts of biases that come into play but
that being said we're not number one
anyway coronavirus debts are they way
down well they're down and we kind of
expect them to come up the reason I'm
saying this is because we see the cases
going up but the deaths aren't going up
so president Trump is taking this as a
positive sign but I approach that with a
little bit of skepticism usually there's
a lag time between Cova 19 initial
infection and then death because it
takes time to succumb to the virus and
then it takes time to report that death
second we're seeing a lot of young folks
get infected with this virus and
generally speaking they have a lower
mortality rate than the people who are
over the age of 50 or 60 and then the
final point is we have some treatments
out there REM nezha bier dexamethasone
both treatments that are being used in
the severely ill hoping to prevent or
lower the chance of death we also learn
how to manage ventilators better in the
beginning of this pandemic this was a
novel virus we were learning we were
trying different setting
as we've established better parameters
we've done better taking care of
patients with kovat 19 I hope that
President Trump is right and that the
deaths do continue trending downward but
based on the information we have at hand
I don't think we can make that
prediction just yet coronavirus right
come flu what's the purpose of calling
you come flu you're not a stand-up
comedian I'm one to laugh at ourselves
at our problems at our pain I believe
it's therapeutic but not right now not
when the country is polarized we need to
bring people together like this isn't
effective in anything except rallying
his base Kovac Kovac 19 Kovac I say
what's the 19 Kovac 19 some people can't
explain what the 19 give me the Kovac 19
I said that's an odd name there's
nothing odd about Kovac 19 19 stands for
the year that it was found 20 19 it's
almost as if President Trump wants to
demean this virus so much that it's not
as powerful taking the power away from
his campaign but I get a lot of
tremendously positive news on the
hydroxy I talked about
hydroxychloroquine many times on this
channel and on television it really
bothered me when President Trump called
it a game-changer without having any
real good evidence to back that up and
because of that patients took it
unnecessarily potentially had negative
effects as a result and really saw
limited benefit you know the expression
I've used John what do you have to lose
okay what do you have to lose your life
medications even ones that have a known
safety profile have side effects I've
had many patients contact me from home
when they were quite sick and said they
didn't want to go to the hospital they
just wanted me to prescribe
hydroxychloroquine because they saw
President Trump make statements like
this and it took a lot of counseling to
explain what they could lose they can
get an arrhythmia they can lose their
lives as a result of this arrhythmia
because they're taking this medication
without getting an EKG first there's a
lot of reasons why doctors don't
prescribe medications willy-nilly and
one of them is side effect that's
probably the most important one of them
all let's talk second wait
it's at the tip of everyone's tongue
we're all worried about it what's the
deal with the second wait here's what
our politicians think there is no second
wave coming it's just you know hot spots
they send in CDC teams we've got the
testing procedures we've got the
Diagnostics we've got the PPE and so I
really think it's a pretty good
situation only Larry Kudlow can go on
television say it's a pretty good
situation when we're hitting the biggest
peak we've had with covin 19 cases like
it just doesn't make sense to me like
you're lying to yourself and in fact
it's not the first time laddering Kudlow
has went on TV and said something quite
inaccurate we have contained this I
won't say airtight that's pretty close
to airtight no Larry Kudlow it's July
and we still have not contained this
we're still experiencing all-time highs
despite the European Union having a very
low number of cases so we're clearly
doing something wrong and we have to be
forthcoming and honest about it but
Larry Kudlow did say one thing
accurately there is no second way but
that's only because we haven't even left
the first wave the cases of Cova 19
spiked the united states we were happy
they didn't spike that high we did all
the social distancing and then we
relaxed everything and what do you know
he just continues going right back up
how has Larry Kudlow and President Trump
not changed their talking points when
the numbers are clearly going up we
shouldn't be using kovat 19 as a chess
piece in a political game we need to be
looking at these numbers honestly we
need to be giving accurate information
to the public so they can make the best
decisions and actions for themselves and
their families until we can put our
political nonsense aside we will not get
anywhere because the general public is
confused i watch media I'm confused I
have to read dense research in order to
figure out what's going on the average
person cannot do that therefore they're
led astray we need a non-biased
approach to kovin 19 let's stop playing
the blame game and just give the
accurate information of what's going on
an accurate non-political snapshot
as well as some guidelines that aren't
political as well covering your face in
public
to protect a community is not a
political statement you do not need to
put on a make America great again hat
and put the mask over your eyes to show
how cool you are and at the same time if
you see someone not wearing a mask
yelling at them won't help the situation
either explaining to them why the mask
is important could be a step but yelling
at them is only going to make the
problem worse and the polarization
continue to trend upwards we need to do
this smartly non politically and in a
scientific way all in all I have this
final message for President Trump you
are the leader of the United States the
country that I call home that my family
escaped to from Russia your
responsibility to people to be honest to
be forthcoming with information that we
can use to protect ourselves and our
family members please avoid sarcastic
jokey or even mean rhetoric when talking
about kovat 19 it creates confusion and
confusion in the midst of a pandemic
costs people their lives I'm a frontline
healthcare worker the last thing I want
to see is my patients get sick or even
my colleagues get sick you have the
ability to bring this nation together
but you have to do that by starting to
be honest forthcoming and unifying in
your message
you